ce nu ce matin à 6h30 dans la fnai kivu
sud vers 5 heures du matin et j'ai eu la
motivation et voilà c'est la première
fois que je vais la voir je pense que la
pression va monter quand je la verrai je
m'adonne stephanie meyer
émotion ses puissantes si sa volonté a
survécu avec ses souvenirs
ra peut-être de l'intérieur est-ce que
mélanie est toujours là
je me dis qu elle était géniale elle
avait écrit à les meilleurs livres
puissent exister que j'ai faim ils
étaient juste incroyable est que la
remercier tellement pour tout ce qu'elle
avait fait ça fait six ans que j'attends
de rencontrer et c'est enfin on vous
donne une réalité c'est on réalise pas
vraiment enfants s'est pas encore
réellement non je pense qu'on a réalisé
plus tard mais là on n'y croit pas
encore en fait
quand je lis univers de stephenie meyer
que ce soit
avec ap
sa mère
ça me donnait beaucoup d'émotion à
travers c'est ça que j'aime c'est que on
passe du rire aux couleurs et à mon
coeur qui parle d'histoire avec le
personnage et jarret avoir montré à
m'identifier
nous avons été envahis par une autre
espèce
qui a éliminé nos esprits et pris
possession de nos cordes
les certains d'entre nous continuent de
lutter
celui-ci british
herve penot du maintien
c'est super différente et j'ai mis
beaucoup de temps à me mettre dans le
livre parce que je voulais pas d'un
remake est en fait c'est tout aussi bien
les grilles super prenant en rendre
vraiment dedans tellement que je vais
lui deux fois de suite parce que j'en
avais pas eu assez donc ça n'a rien à
voir mais c'est elle est super pareil
j'ai regardé tout ce qui était possible
de regarder sur le film donc 1000 tr
l'heure j'ai vu ça donne vraiment envie
j'ai hâte d'être le jour j et puis bah
ça corresponde quand même bien à ce
qu'on voit dans le livre donc après on
espère que ça ira jusqu'au bout mais
maintenant ça ça parait premier handicap
j'ai réalisé un de mes rêves c'est
magique quoi y'a pas d'autres mots pour
magic